question from nathan flesher on twitter
is zach wilson so good that you would
advise the houston texans to prioritize
trading watson to the jets in a package
that would include the pick
allowing the texans to get wilson for
themselves yeah well i guess
yes yes i mean you know desean watson's
not doesn't want to be there i mean
that's very apparent now
i mean zach wilson yeah you know when i
say he's rogers or mahomes that's you
know i think he's the the damn man right
there so yes he's worth that but you
know what is what is going to be the
other aspects of that trade again you
know too that that's what you you'd have
to figure out and are the jets you know
i don't know that that's an interesting
that's an interesting proposition and
i'd have to kind of look that and figure
that out what that trade value would be
exactly to figure that because really
mike when you think about that okay the
the texans where they're picking they're
gonna have to trade up of course they're
trading a proven commodity for a guy uh
who yes we don't know about yet but you
know i think is special and of course he
costs a lot less money too than desean
watson so there's that aspect of it so
i'd have to work out kind of the trade
particulars there to try to figure that
out but it's an interesting thought
nonetheless my big thing with the jets
just as you always have heard there's
just so many holes on the roster i just
don't
i don't want to see them
give up you know the kitchen sink and
the house and everything just to get one
guy and then we're sitting here hey we
got one guy who's a superstar but we got
a lot of crap around him again and
that's where i think you know the jets
got to be careful because they got a lot
of holes to fill on that team
and remember this it's not the second
overall pick
it's trading for zach wilson or trevor
lawrence worst case scenario so that
changes the value that changes the
dynamic and if the texans happen to fall
in love with zach wilson and and really
whatever the texans do if they
give in to desean watson's trade demand
they they need to have a quarterback
moving forward and if if nick casario
starts watching a bunch of zack wilson
film and reacts the same way you did
all of a sudden there's a potential
strategy for giving watson what he wants
you get zach wilson and maybe you don't
need to give up as much other stuff
right the jets yeah if casario falls in
love with wilson of course then it
becomes the poker
game of bluffing and keeping your cards
close to the vest and not acting like
you love a guy that you truly love
that's that's a big part of the silly
but very real aspect of the draft you
act like you don't like the guys you
like and you act like you like the guys
you don't but that that's part of it
because it's no longer the second
overall pick once it becomes cemented
that it's zach wilson you're trading
zach wilson not just some nameless
faceless pick in the draft yeah no
you're exactly right i mean you think if
you're making that trade you're making
it to
we want this guy a la like the eagles
did with carson wentz back in the day
right they made a move they they had the
information that the rams were gonna go
golf and okay we're trading up to go to
this and get this guy uh it it's a it's
an interesting conversation and it's a
very good question and what the value of
that is i don't know i'd have to kind of
think about that a little bit uh because
i'm just seeing this question myself
here as we sit down and do this but man
i'm excited for what the jets have in
front of them i'm really in because of
all those options we've talked about you
know listen i i you know i'm a giants
fan here in new york i'm not a i'm not
the kind of giant sin that like hates
the new york jets i don't and of course
with robert sala coming from you know
kyle shanahan and the san francisco
49ers i'm rooting for him and i've liked
a lot of what joe douglas has done too
so uh i'm excited to see how they
approach this and yeah they're gonna
they're gonna have to play chess here in
this one and uh it's it's gonna be one
of the themes of the off season and then
and in that aspect the desean watson
trade to the jets maybe is not dead when
you talk about it like that to where i
would have gone no you don't do that
don't do it don't do it but there like
you said it might lessen the value to
where you don't have to give up too much
to do it and it's an interesting angle
to kind of wrap your head around
one key aspect of that conversation is
deshawn watson has to
buy in to play for the jets and wave his
no trade clause i always thought giants
fans didn't care about the jets because
they weren't threatened by the jets
because the jets perennially stink well
yeah i think that's i i think that's
fair if they were good you'd have a
different feeling maybe about it if
they'd won four super bowls since 1986
and you're waiting for your second one
after 50 exactly you'd feel differently
about the jets probably you're exactly
right it's a little bit like the yankees
and the mets like i don't hate the mets
because they're not a threat to the
yankees at all i go no i hate the red
sox i don't care about the mets and
pete's booing me yeah pete sorry poor
life decision by you and choosing the
mets i don't know what you did there but
i think p is pete the only new yorker
who likes the giants and the mets
yankees or jets mets it's a rare combo
yeah it is a rare combo there's a few
every now and then and of course it
would be pete who does that yes i mean
of course that's him that makes sense
the the matt casey chimes in at least we
have a soul
so
he is mets jets he is i'm trying to keep
all this straight right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports